Speaker 1: We are now going to talk about
Florida.
What is going on in Florida, Florida has quickly
become a covid health escape, we are seeing
more cases basically in all of the United
States.
As I mentioned earlier, in part, it's because
of the more contagious Delta variant, and
in part, it's because not nearly enough people
have been vaccinated, if you can believe it.
As of yesterday afternoon, only forty nine
point six percent of the United States has
been fully vaccinated.
We are not even at 50 percent yet.
Even though vaccines are widely available,
safe and free, they are free.
So cases are spiking in lots of places.
But in many of these places, hospitalizations
are not spiking nearly as much or at all because
of the high vaccination rates.
So like Vermont would be one such example.
And there are many that you can find.
The U.S. state of Florida, which has become
a cartoonish Trumpy in farce, led by Republican
Governor Rhonda Santurce, was hit not only
has hit not only a new single day pandemic
long case record, but it has also reached
a record level of covid hospitalization right
now, today, right now, as we are recording
Today show, there is a record number of hospitalization
for covid in the state of Florida.
What is Ron Descenders doing?
He is trying to ban any kind of mask mandates
and get everybody in school.
Now, as you can see here, Florida is setting
its own new single day case record.
They did it on July 31st with almost twenty
two thousand cases, depending on the day.
Florida is regularly registering between 20
and 30 percent of the entire country's new
cases.
That's in one state, the state of Florida.
But if it were merely cases among vaccinated
people for whom it's mostly a cold, it wouldn't
be that big of a deal.
But Florida's hospitals are completely filling
up.
First of all, check out the positivity rates
in Florida, which are eighteen point one percent
for the state.
In Broward County, it's a 14 percent positivity
rate.
Miami-Dade, 12 percent.
Monroe County, 16 percent positivity.
If your positivity rate is above about five,
it means you're not testing nearly enough
and you're not capturing nearly enough of
the people who are sick.
When when you have an 18 percent positivity
rate, it means there's tons of people not
getting tested who have the virus and are
spreading the virus.
And then maybe most importantly, hospitalizations
are at a record.
The Associated Press reporting that Florida
breaks covid-19 hospitalization record with
more than ten thousand two hundred patients.
The Sunshine State had ten thousand two hundred
and seven people hospitalized with confirmed
covid cases, according to data reported to
the U.S. Department of HHS.
The previous record was from July 23 of twenty
twenty more than half a year before vaccinations
were widespread.
So understand that hospitalization today in
Florida is about 20 percent higher than before
anybody was vaccinated.
Florida is now leading the nation in per capita
hospitalizations.
Some people saying, well, David, sir, Florida
has so many people.
Yes, but Florida is also leading per capita
hospitalizations.
In the last week, Florida is averaging 1500
adult hospitalizations a day.
And listen to this, 35 pediatric hospitalizations
every day, 35 kids in Florida are being put
into the hospital with covid.
And then what about deaths?
Well, because part of Florida is vaccinated,
we don't expect the death rate to get as high.
But deaths are also climbing in Florida much
more than nationally.
Daily deaths in Florida, they were down to
22 a day.
They're now up to fifty five a day, more than
doubled.
And based on the recent case explosion, we
would expect dramatically higher death counts
in Florida in the next 15 to 20 days.
Meanwhile, Governor Ron DeSantis is almost
campaigning for the virus, bragging about
we're not going to do mask mandates, we're
not going to do guidelines, were never shutting
anything down.
We're opening everything, do everything, send
kids to school, but no masks in school.
If you were trying to have the worst numbers
in the country, you'd basically be doing what
Rhonda Santurce is doing in Florida.
Will it get him negative consequences or will
he end up as the Republican presidential nominee
in 2024?
That's the question.
And because we do have a real problem in this
country with ignorance, I am not ready to
say this will definitely hurt Ron DeSantis.
It's it's possible that somehow, because of
the Republican electorate, Rhonda Santos comes
out of this looking like a.
Freedom loving hero, rather than a covid hell
scape creating lunatic remains to be seen.
We'll have more on the explosive situation
in Florida on our Instagram.
You can find us on Instagram The David Pakman
Show and find me on Instagram at David Pakman.